so the Hollywood Reporter says that
jason momoa AKA Khal Drogo AKA Ronin
decks will play Aquaman in the new cycle
of disease my first reaction optimism
momona is the best hope to dispel the
jokes about Aquaman being the lamest of
all superheroes seriously you want to
crack jokes about this guy chatting with
the fishies I think he can pull off the
badass new 52 version of the sea man my
second reaction was dread because I was
certain that comment threads would be
full of people griping about how you
simply can't cast someone who isn't
blonde in the role of Aquaman my fears
were justified see the same sort of
person who gripes oh you can't have a
female for you can't have a black
electro or I'm dollar human torch or
Nick Fury well they're out in force
proclaiming that this casting decision
is an outrage now I don't want to say
that these people are bigots clamoring
for an Aryan underseat ubermensch but
this is where geeky nitpicking and
excessive literal mindedness gets to be
genuinely troubling now I get outraged
about casting decisions Hollywood
casting Kelsey Grammer as beast was a
sacrilege because Frasier beast can't be
Frasier what one person may like another
may not if it doesn't mean that they're
one of them is right the other is wrong
but Hollywood turning the Nick Fury into
a black man or Aquaman into a Pacific
Islander simply reflects the fact these
characters were created in an era that
didn't value diversity just ask mr.
Stanley Lieber who found it was
professionally helpful to change his
name to Stanley and who by the way
heartily endorse the idea of casting
Donald Glover as Peter Parker news flash
none of the classic comic book
characters were actually Caucasian
anyway and I don't want to get all royal
icked and Steen on you but if you zoom
in 10x or 20 axon amazing fantasy number
fantastic for number one you'll notice
that the skin of these seemingly
Caucasian characters is actually
stippled with magenta ben de dots race
is a construct in comic books as well as
IRL insisting that all movie characters
must be the same ethnicity as their
comic book versions is as simplistic as
saying that you can't remake an asian
movie in the West because it's
whitewashing or something I mean granted
remakes a Bangkok dangerous and old boy
and the grudge work failures but some
Western remix are great like Fistful of
Dollars the department Reservoir Dogs
fess up Tarantino it's a total rip off
of ringgold am city on fire are you
gonna tell a cure course our that he
shouldn't have transplanted
Shakespeare's Macbeth or King Lear to
feudal Japan are you going to tell
George Lucas that he can't transfer
Kurosawa's hidden fortress to a galaxy
far far away are you going to tell Diana
Ross and Michael Jackson that they can't
make a funky all black wizard of oz I
want to see more creative casting and
transpose locales I want an Acura set in
Detroit I want to see a game Vietnamese
Batman no not ambiguous Joel Schumacher
style I want an openly gay Vietnamese
fan a blonde Aquaman I mean can you
imagine if they cast a light haired guy
as a James Bond that would be oh let me
know if you want the next James Bond to
be a ginger in the comments and
subscribe to the wired channel